put us here we don't know what's up
there the mains high Mike's a mile from
FX guide.com for wide looking at the
complex creature work in Maze Runner in
the new film based on the book of the
same name director Wes ball worked with
method Studios Vancouver to create the
maze that Thomas and the other gliders
find themselves in along with the
relentless grievers that chase them the
film was shot on location and much of
the exterior running action was done
with careful attention given to make
sure that the shadows of where the giant
maze would be cast correctly over the
actors on set there was actually only a
tiny amount of the real maze built given
that the location was very remote and
the team had to carry in most of their
extra gear by hand as complex as the
moving parts of the maze were for
method' studios to realize the maze
grievers actually were so complicated
they required an entirely new creature
pipeline to be developed highly detailed
bone and mechanical limb logic had to be
developed for exactly how these
creatures might have evolved the
structure detailed and worked out to
allow the weight distribution to move
correctly and the range of movement to
be believable this allowed for
simulations to be done to work out
physical weight distribution and flesh
Sims methods VFX supervisor su-ro
recruited james jacob fresh from doing
the goblin king and the original Hobbit
film equator to canada to make the
grievers look believable and organic
while still being half mechanical the
grievers can be a little hard to study
while they're attacking but thankfully
methods Geo's produced for us this
exclusive video showing how the
creatures are internally formed James's
big thing was he would build the
character and the skeleton to be correct
and it has to be organ amelie correct
based in sort of natural physics so we
built the skeleton we built the muscles
and that's how the character was going
to move facing the grievers in a shot
required not only tracking and contact
lighting but also complex fire
simulations and deed
interaction with the actors the
directory's himself actually a highly
accomplished VFX artist in his own right
having won the role of directing on this
film on the basis of the work he did on
his own short film ruin which he made by
himself he came from background where he
would know that you know tan roto
something would be really tricky and so
he would always be aware of that kind of
thing and sometimes I just laugh ago
don't worry about that over there
there's a whole 3d city behind us that's
moving not to spoil the film or anything
but this is only the first of four books
in the series so hopefully we'll see
beyond the maze but for now don't forget
to subscribe for more behind the scenes
action I'm Mike Seymour a wide
you